just [ __ ] yeah it's a interesting think
that documentary was a main change my I
open my eyes and I had a piss test the
next day as well okay yeah I told the
guy I've seen this I saw this on the
documentary last night the little cup
that we're using so yeah I was like who
knows who's on steroids and when you
devalue you saw that came through you
know the guys that kind of like their
bodies changed somebody who dropped off
radically yeah
so quick really quick like oh damn I
never thought yeah my it's not just
changed but changed to the point where
like you're not even the same person
yeah you're like doing an important
cause in their 20s doing him an
impression of who they were just a
couple years ago on the sauce yeah
shit's happening man Nowitzki is a good
guy man he's just like he's got a bad
reputation from a lot of people that
could be cool with him cuz I'm you know
I'm not cheating I'm not a guy that
anymore I mean now he's what is his
official title
it's like athletes those how much you
don't want to be hanging around him like
the wire would or wouldn't be as
friendly with him because they don't
want him sniffing around he's there to
make sure that's funny yeah oh I'm glad
he's around honestly cuz you know you
want I don't mind being an ambassador
for the sport it's like a clean sport
cuz yeah back in the day even as early
as 2010 hey Tim Sylvia Tim Sylvia record
its own fight passing on that's it oh I
can't find it anywhere
damn it's weird like we look at him
talking this like oh right because you
many times yeah I know it's weird being
here right that's weird for me too man
believe